Move over, supermodels!
Japan's robo model is ready for the catwalk.
Scientists unveiled a new humanoid walking robot,...
...they say, is capable of walking the catwalk at fashion shows.
The robot has a female face that makes several sexy expressions.
Scientists say they are still working out the kinks in the robot's technology,...
...but they are impressed with her performance so far.
The HRP4C was designed to look like a Japanese woman,...
...although its silver and black body makes it appear to be wearing a spacesuit.
The robot isn't capable of wearing clothes yet.
The framework without the face and other skin costs $200,000.
The programmers say they will soon make the technology available to the public,...
...so others can come up with fun facial expressions and dance moves for her.
For MSNBC.com, I'm Dara Brown.